saturday marked the fourth summit of the
community of latin american and
caribbean states or select and this
year's international dialogue held in
mexico city was full of surprises
starting with the unexpected appearance
of venezuela's nicolas maduro who
arrived unannounced overnight
the visit placed maduro across the table
from other leftist leaders at a summit
that excludes the participation of the
united states
we have enough stones to throw at some
of you but we didn't come here to throw
stones we came to extend our hand and
work together
not everyone at the 2021 selak summit
was welcoming of the venezuelan
delegation
my presence at this summit in no way
represents a recognition of the
government of mr nicolas maduro
my government has not changed its
position and i believe it's between
gentlemen to say this face to face
another unexpected appearance was
chinese president xi jinping who sent a
pre-recorded message promising more
cooperation between china and latin
america
the ties between china and latin america
have entered a new era characterized by
equality mutual benefit innovation and
well-being of the people
nearly 20 heads of state participated in
the summit including cuba's miguel
diaz-canel the cuban leader called for
an end to u.s sanctions and was among
many who criticized the organization of
american states calling the oas a tool
of u.s interests
it is the oas at the service of the
united states that has supported
attempts to isolate cuba military
interventions in latin america and the
caribbean government overthrows and
military dictatorships
host mexican president andres manuel
lopez obrador went further saying latin
american and caribbean nations should
aspire to form a regional bloc similar
to the european union
in these times silac can become the
principal instrument to consolidate
relations between our latin american and
caribbean nations
[Music]
despite moments of contention there was
also agreement among select members
including building on a regional
strategy to face the challenges of the
coronavirus pandemic
and establishing a regional fund to
serve as relief during natural disasters
linked to climate change
the 2021 cell act conference is seen by
many as an opportunity for mexico to
position itself as a power player and a
regional mediator working toward
restoring multilateralism and ending the
diplomatic rift that exists between the
united states and leftist latin american
countries like cuba and venezuela manuel
rapalo al jazeera mexico city